[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
the informant is missing
I know where to look
I know where to find the informant
as Jim Comer and the Republicans check
Connor Biden's laptop
apparently all the evidence is hiding
there maybe that's where the informant
is hiding I don't know who can tell
really
that there's a narrator there is no
informant there's come on man we know
it's a lie we know it's all [__]
the entire time I even said it when they
were doing the press conference that
this was all distraction from Donald
Trump
being charged and found guilty of
sexually assaulting Eugene Carroll and
defaming her
that's all it was that's it
they're working this up
so that they could pop that down in the
news of Donald Trump
got the distraction
so we wouldn't talk about how he grabbed
Eugene Carroll by the [__]
what I mean what else do you want
what else do you want they can't find I
can't find them for me
it's a spy come on the [__] out of here
with this nonsense there was no
informant there's no lab top there's no
crime Biden family or Biden crime family
however you want to type it out on
Twitter you [__] chuckleheads it
doesn't exist
and the more you try the worse it looks
really so keep going
keep going keep talking about the
informant and how the informant's
missing
go ahead
makes you look like fools
we've always known and by we I mean
people with [__] two brain cells to
rub together we've always known that the
hunter Biden lamp top [__]
was just absolute garbage
it's [__]
nowhere anywhere had they provided any
evidence of any crime none whatsoever
none on the contrary there there are
hundreds
hundreds of trump supporters who have
been charged and convicted
handfuls that have been convicted of the
crime of seditious conspiracy
and yet they're still gonna nominate
Donald Trump who tried to over overthrow
our government and become the dictator
[__] out of here you people yelling and
screaming about the biting crime family
hey how about you take care of your own
first huh how about that
how about you just take care of your own
and Jim Jordan is the one that's gonna
preach to us about crime when he looks
the other way when student athletes are
being sexually assaulted come on man
[__] out of here we're supposed to take
you people seriously
[__] you
and and we're supposed to believe that
the reason why you're not gonna have the
evidence
why there's no there's no way to bring
charges because the informant is now
missing
you don't lose whistleblowers you don't
lose informants
I mean unless they're imaginary
it was a huge rake step it was a huge
face plant they keep digging in their
political grave and they can't stop
don't take the shovel out of their hand
when they're digging their political
grave let them continue
and that's why we're going to talk about
how their informant is missing their
informant is lost they don't have any
whistleblowers it's all [__] it's
all a [__] manga lie to protect one
person and one person only that's it
Donald [__] Trump that's right all
these lies all this [__] is to
somehow run [__] distraction for
Grandpa poopy pants so no one figures
out that he's a sexual abuser
as if the country didn't already [__]
know that
he's just now convicted of it has to pay
five million bucks because of that and
the defamation when he said
she wasn't his type to sexually assault
he said that [__]
what do you want for me
he's like I wouldn't sexually assault
her she's not good looking enough now
but when she was she looked like my wife
Marla boy I sure would then
that's why he lost that was the best
defense he had
by the way
oh Rhonda santis
goes to Iowa this weekend
oh man and Trump pretends he's scared of
tornadoes did you catch this
did you get this is one of the biggest
wedges we can actually drive between
these some [__] now don't Don't Take
Your Eye Off the Ball obviously the
house are at Republican rat House of
Representatives
they're more focused on imaginary
[__] whistleblowers and informants
than they are making sure that the full
faith and credit of the United States is
intact they're not gonna yeah they don't
give a [__] about that
again I if I was Biden I would just let
them [__] do it and use the 14th and
get rid of the debt ceiling that's what
I would do if I was if I was the
president if I was Joe Biden
I would tell the Republicans fine don't
[__] do it whatever you want to do if
you don't want to do your job fine I'll
do my job and I'll 14th that [__]
it he can use the 14th Amendment
to keep paying the bills of the United
States keep paying the Appropriations
that Trump and his administration the
Republican Congress appropriated after
astronomical amounts of debt
because they paid the richest of the
rich in this country with tax cuts
and cut and trying to cut benefits from
veterans and increase their own pay
that's a whole nother [__] rant
let's get back to Iowa and the wedge
that we can draw because we can't we
can't keep our eye off the House of
Representatives that's the most
important race in 2024 to be quite
honest to win back the House of
Representatives and to smash up these
super majorities in these red states of
Republicans maybe win a few Senate seats
and maybe win some governorships anyways
I digress from that we'll get back to
that it's a whole nother [__] rant
there's just too much [__] and this is
this is their goal really is have as
much chaos as they possibly can
so that way
um that we have to [__] it's like
playing wakamaga right
whack-a-magalai here whack a Maga live
there just keep whacking them
and they just keep lying they keep
popping up anyways back to Iowa Donald
Trump is apparently terrified of the
possibility of tornadoes
that's what he says I actually believe
that people in Iowa are not that
terrified of the possibility of
tornadoes they're kind of used to
tornado warnings
they're kind of used to it there wasn't
tornado warnings anywhere near where he
was going to be
there was no delays at any airports
where he was going to land
the fact of the matter is is that Donald
Trump
has told us a big lie
and and a lot of America believes it
not not that not that he won the
election not that he won the 2020 like
that's not the big lie I'm talking about
the big lie I'm talking about is that he
has massive amounts of support
enthusiastic support
he doesn't it's all [__] it's always
been [__] you look at these [__]
rallies
and half the people at the [__] rally
are the same [__] that were at
the last rally
my guess is is that someone's paying for
their plane tickets to go from rally to
Rally to Rally to Rally
[__] out of here with this nonsense he's
got big support
are you kidding me
you can't convince me of that [__]
how many people have you met outside the
[__] internet
outside your replies on the internet
how many people have you met who are who
are super enthusiastic
about Trump being president again or at
all ever
let's think about it for a second think
about your think about it
think about it it's how many people do
you actually have that you have met
person to person that maybe someone
you're acquainted with
someone you see on a regular basis that
you know for sure
is more enthusiastic about Trump than
Jesus Christ
think about it there aren't that many of
them
again I keep telling you this that Trump
is going to be the nominee and it's
going to be the nominee based on
affiliation alone and the reason why is
because they're the party of [__]
losers their ideology is [__] they have
no good ideas they have no policy the
only the only kind of legislation that
they want to pass is for big government
fascism to tell you what you can and
can't do who you can and can't love what
you can and can't read what you can and
can't [__] learn
fascism
they have they have no [__] ideas the
ideas they have [__] suck and they
know that we know that their ideas
[__] suck
so they base they're basing everything
on affiliation alone
but in Iowa
this weekend it all comes to a head
because you have folks you have folks
that were like ow
Trump said there's the actual tornadoes
there was a tornado at his rally and he
he was he he was gonna come but he did
come and then he used uh a super duper
lasso to get rid of the tornado and then
the head of camps it's to he's super
cool and then you had people who support
Rhonda santis
who are seizing on any opportunity for
Ron to get in the race which he again
Ron Ron dude man just [__] do it
you're you're not again you're not gonna
win in these primaries and you're gonna
get trounced
so you might as well start to build up a
coalition now
because you're gonna lose them
but Ronda santis goes to Iowa he's in
he's in Tornado Alley in Iowa this
weekend
um awkwardly laughing and
seeming to do human things like order
breakfast and with Mike Pence I don't
know where the fly was and to seemingly
do human things like shake hands
um it's these are things that Android
Republican Androids
don't typically do but they have to
pretend like you know
they're not just in a human skin suit
I know they gotta pretend like their
actual Homo sapiens to some degree
without much success because Ron descent
Governor weirdo oh my God and you should
have seen the defense
of Ron DeSantis so there's a picture
going around of Ron DeSantis pretending
that he's laughing I think is what it
looks like to me
it it really does look like and you
remember Men in Black
when and you know they they would they
would dress up the aliens in the human
suits right
they weren't really humans they just
look like humans a lot of times they
were aliens inside this Android suit
skin thing right
that's what Ron DeSantis reminds me of
and it really feels like Mike Pence is
from the same planet
and Mike Pence and Ron DeSantis meet in
a diner
and awkwardly look at each other
and try to figure out which one of them
calls their wife mother more than the
other
I don't know I don't know what the [__]
it was it's [__] weird man
but the Rhonda Santa supporters think
that Rhonda Santos is now going to take
over the race
because he went to Iowa and and looked
really [__] awkward doing it
I'm DeSantis in the race
what what what better content could we
get than Ronda Santos and Donald Trump
continuing to try to one-up each other
and Donald Trump absolutely destroying
Ron DeSantis future in the Republican
party what could be better than that
there's nothing that could please me
more
these two [__] chuckleheads are not
gonna win they're not I don't give a
[__] which one it is it's gonna be Trump
but I don't give a [__] which one it is
and let me tell you something any any
[__] liberals out there that are
terrified of Ron DeSantis being the
nominee don't be
I don't know if you watched how awkward
he was he's not gonna get any less
awkward he's not going to get better at
this
and this morning he's talking about how
he's going to tell colleges what they
can and can't have as far as curriculum
he's a [__] he's a [__] fascist
he's a Theocratic fascist
and he's awkward and weird as hell
and he doesn't relate to I don't know
just like uh humans
he's very bad at appearing to be human
he's horrible at it
absolutely dismal
so yeah do I want Rhonda's answers in
the race [__] yeah I do
I want Donald Trump and race [__] yeah I
do do I want Donald Trump to have to
continue to make excuses and cancel his
rallies and Ron DeSantis weirdly show up
in those same areas and give us
photo after photo video after video of
how awkward that [__] is yes
that is what I want
folks the presidential election is only
important because we must get turnout
that's it that's it
Biden's listen to me listen
stop watching tyt and listen to them
about Marianne Williamson it ain't gonna
happen she ain't gonna be on the stage
neither neither is [__] Bob Kennedy
Jr that [__] Wackadoo they're not
gonna be on stage with Biden it's not
gonna happen no matter you can gel and
scream and [__] unfair whatever you
want to do listen the facts are the
facts it's not gonna happen don't
no Democratic incumbent president has to
debate it's not how it's set up if you
don't like it go be a member of the
party work your way up in the party
become the head chair of the party and
change it
there you go if you want to solve the
problem that's the problem you have to
solve not that there's no other Democrat
there's only one it's the incumbent
president in the Democratic party that's
how it's worked for a long time
and if you don't realize that and you're
not able to wrap your head around that's
how it works then you haven't been
paying attention okay it's just how it
works
now let's go to the Republican side okay
the Republican side
the incumbent
for all intents and purposes is Trump
and they're gonna go with the guy it
doesn't matter how many crimes he's been
charged with how many indictments it
doesn't matter if he's sitting in a jail
cell my guess is folks here's my guess
and we'll see how all the chips fall
after next year's race in 2024
my guess is
that
Donald Trump will be the nominee in 2024
and it is very possible being convicted
and found guilty of several crimes it is
possible that this [__] will be
the nominee in 2028.
I mean I'm not religious but
Praise Jesus
this morning at speaking of Ron DeSantis
and Trump this morning uh Ronda Santos I
just watched a clip of him being asked
if Trump's a [__] loser
and he basically says yeah he's a
[__] loser he lost here he lost here
he lost here he lost here he lost here
guess what's going to happen
Rhonda santis is going to lose in the
primaries it's going to be very clear
probably by by mid-February early March
that Trump is the nominee
and DeSantis will bow out and he will
support Trump full-throated he will go
and say Trump's the only thing
he's not a loser he's the greatest ever
I love my daddy orange Mussolini Jesus
it's what they'll be saying
foreign
but I encourage the Republican Party
to nominate Trump in 2024 and do the
same thing in 2028 [__] yeah let's do
that
hell's to the yeah and I hope he
announces before the 2026 midterms
so he can try to keep his ass out of
prison because that's what I I'm
guessing I'm guessing what he's gonna do
to mount a campaign to 2028. you you
people think I'm crazy
you think I'm nuts but I'm telling you
I'm I'm telling you the guy can't stop
because he's been told his only way out
of these federal charges and these
federal indictments is to be the
president of the United States he's
obsessed with it
he's [__] obsessed with it
and he'll stop at nothing to pretend
that he's going to be president
just like he stopped at nothing to
pretend to be president when he held the
office
doubt me on this go ahead you try it
but Ron
um because I've been telling Rhonda
santis this Ron look man honestly just
do it just get in the [__] race man
you're you're killing time
that you don't have
you're killing time that you don't have
speaking speaking of don't have
I wonder what I wonder what new excuse
the Republicans how many we'll probably
count them up over the week of how and
why their informant is now missing and
lost
did they did they vote them off the
island of the Trump reality show we all
know what this Hunter Biden [__] is and
what this press conference was last week
I told you this it was all distraction
to distract from the guilty verdict of
Donald Trump being a sexual assaulter
that's all it is that's what it was
they were working it up they don't have
evidence it's all [__] they're
running they're running [__]
distraction for for King Maga okay
that's all it is it's all lies it's all
[__] the entirety of it
and and really honestly it's it's
beautiful
you couldn't you couldn't get a worse
execution
of Republicans trying to make Biden the
criminal when their guy is the actual
criminal than this
like yeah we got we got evidence that
people with the name Baden
did transaction they they they took
money can you believe that have you ever
took money in your life have you ever
got a paycheck have you ever been paid
for something has anyone ever wrote you
a check
well you're a criminal and any Biden
that receives any money anywhere in any
form whatsoever is a criminal even if we
don't have any evidence of any crimes
and they're really pissed off that's the
thing they're really mad about here is
that they haven't found any crime yet
not just with Joe Biden because that's
obvious that they haven't found anything
because even Jim Comer can't admit
he's like well it really does sure seem
like crime and if it's not crime it
should be if it is legal it shouldn't be
legal it should be illegal and we should
be able to toss Biden and gitmo like my
Q Anon Facebook page says
Jim Comer you are a dumb son of a [__]
and I hope you keep going what what the
[__] did they think was gonna happen
when they put Jim Comer
in charge of the oversight committee
the chair he's the chairman
could someone look that fact up for me
did they really do that
okay yeah they did they did the
Republicans put a cuein on her in charge
of the oversight Committee in our
Congress and they thought that the
outcome was going to be spectacular
Jim Comer who who has been accused of
domestic assault
they thought that was their guy
who who is more of a q Anon cult member
than Jeannie Thomas Clarence Thomas's
Maga wife
they thought that was going to be a good
idea
and then to top it off they're like you
know what we'll do you know what we'll
do we'll put
we'll put Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan
the person
who looked the other way
when his student athletes said he was
that he was responsible for were being
sexually and molested and assaulted he
looked the other way
we're gonna put him in charge of
Judiciary because that makes total sense
ah yeah that'll be great
the American people won't laugh at us at
all
folks
this is Maga
and and they're not going anywhere okay
I I know I know it's frustrating and I
know you think oh this is the end of it
this is gonna be close to the end and
we're so we're not
we're not
this is the Republican party it always
has been
that's the big [__] secret here
this has always been who the Republicans
are
they were just never so emboldened to be
themselves
and to pull back that thin veil of
conservatism that they were hiding
fascism with
yes are there still some Republicans and
still some anti-trumpers and never
trumpers out there that want to get back
to the thin veiled fascism of course
they do they understand that they're not
going to win if they don't
that's why we can't let them
we have to be loud we have to continue
to be fascisms Kryptonite and yell and
scream at the top of our lungs
and get the truth out there in front of
the American people because they're not
paying attention yes they're not paying
attention
there's a lot of people on this show
every single day that come here and
listen for two full hours
but people and out there in the country
aren't paying attention aren't listening
although they should they should come
here here right here at the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch do not forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel you don't want to miss a
single episode also download every
single episode on Apple Spotify and
Google you can watch it on Facebook too
if you still have a Facebook account or
you troll around on Facebook just follow
us at the Tony Michaels you can watch us
over there I want to tell you something
the twitch we've got over 1100 followers
now on Twitch it is free to follow us on
Twitch go follow us on Twitch also if
you have your Amazon Prime account
linked to your Twitch account don't
forget to re-subscribe we've had a few
people this morning re-subscribe already
uh poly77 just re-subscribed for three
months in a row that's right if you
linked your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account not only do you have to
give us that one free subscription you
have to renew it every single month I
know it's a pain in the ass they don't
make free money easy they really don't
it's not going to be easy for you to
give us free money it doesn't cost you
anything extra it doesn't cost us
anything but you do have to go in and
just click the button re-subscribe takes
like three seconds three seconds you
know I I should put a link like a video
on how to resubscribe but everyone seems
to be getting it and if you didn't know
this which I know you probably do but if
you are an Amazon Prime subscriber
because it's free to follow us on Twitch
that's free
but if you are an Amazon Prime
subscriber what you can do is link your
Prime account to your Twitch account if
you don't have a Twitch account it's
really easy to create one with your
Amazon Prime account you just go to the
tonymichaels.com that's right go to
thetonymichaels.com there's a link just
down below that says link Amazon and
twitch click that it'll take you to
Amazon gaming you'll be able to link
your two accounts and you'll be able to
give us that one free subscription it
gives us a couple bucks a month
literally but it all adds up and I want
to tell you I appreciate everyone who
has subscribed using their Amazon Prime
account or subscribed in general because
you can do that too if you want to you
can spend the 4.99 and you can subscribe
over on Twitch and we get a couple
dollars of it really if you want to give
us five bucks just if you're gonna go to
the Tony michaels.com just go to the tip
jar and throw the five bucks in the tip
jar because twitch takes a bunch of it a
ton of it they take half of it and then
fees
but when it's Prime when it's the Prime
subscription it it's free for you it's
free for us so thank you for all the
support over on Twitch don't forget to
renew your subscription
um sometime today we got a few people
out there that are in need of
re-subscribing so don't forget to
resubscribe but the the support over
there has been fantastic I can't tell
you how great it is over on Twitch we
got a special guest for you today we're
going to talk about George Santos I
believe that's at the bottom of next
hour now we're gonna go watch some video
of of James Comer and I think
I think representative bird [__] you
remember him represented bird [__] who
said I ain't a goddamn fling we can do
about guns it just we're just gonna have
to have people keep dying [__] it we're
just going on these elementary schools
just gonna have to get shot up because
we can't do anything about it or any
goddamn thing we can do you remember
representative bird [__] his quote on
guns that's him apparently he's gonna
tell us about this missing informant we
need to we need to send a search party
out don't go anywhere we're gonna get to
those clips right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] up we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
it's Monday Monday Monday
yesterday was Mother's Day I hope you
had a safe and happy Mother's Day to all
those who celebrated out there happy
Mother's Day to all the mothers
all the mothers
not just the biological ones [__]
Marjorie Taylor green
uh troglodyte I want to apologize
yesterday we had a great uh celebration
we grilled and we cooked and we had a
some folks over my mom was there and
Aunt my wife was there so we celebrated
uh Mother's Day I wasn't able to do the
patreon thing last night so I want to
apologize I I think we're gonna do like
an ask me anything this week sometime
not to try to make up for it so I
appreciate everyone staying patient
yesterday as we were trying to figure
out our celebrations so and I hope you
all all had a happy happy happy Mother's
Day and to all those who celebrated
Mother's Day
oh boy see we got more people
um following us over on Twitch as we
speak so I want to thank you for that as
well how was your mother's day we're
gonna have Gabe Sanchez here and we have
a special guest um with us
um today we're going to talk about
George Santos
um when this was we were going to have
this gaster her name is Jacqueline sweet
uh we were gonna have this guest on
uh I think Friday last week but the
timing didn't work out we had Benjamin
shalana you guys like Ben
last week
Ben hit
he he was talking about Nazi Germany and
how it relates to today also talking
about the um the film that I've
mentioned before Hitler a career that's
on Netflix
and how it's a very interesting film so
did it did it do someone asked do I
watch Doctor Who Tony do you watch
Doctor Who no I watch Dr what
sorry who's on first what's on second I
don't know who's on third no I don't I
don't I don't watch a lot of TV
fortunately or unfortunately I guess you
could say
I don't really I watch movies I like
movies Sometimes some movies are [__]
but um you know
I have that going
so Jacqueline sweet is going to uh join
us she's a freelance journalist but
she's been covering George Santos
because she's she covers a lot of stuff
on Long Island
um she was actually at the press
conference
of George Santos when he came out of the
the federal courthouse the other day and
announced that he was indicted and
started to do the whole trumpian thing
where it's all Witch Hunt
it's a Witch Hunt you know that sort of
[__] um so she was there so she's going
to give us some insight and I believe I
believe
um
I believe
Chris is asking did he just say he likes
boobies no movies movies boobies movies
I understand how it could sound the same
it is Monday morning
it is Monday movies boobies does it
sound the same
I don't know I mean I'm not gonna say I
don't like boobs I'm not going to say
that either
I mean
there was a thing going around on
Twitter this weekend oh man I'm gonna
get sidetracked here someone said it's
boobs and I get distracted here's the
thing is on Twitter this weekend there
was the um
a bunch of people were posting pictures
of their boobs for the I hate boobs
crowd and not like I mean some of them
might have been naked but most of it
just you know cleavage right
and and it was for the I hate boobs
crowd now I was like who is the I hate
boobs crap but I figured it out was it
was these Republican in cells that's who
it was you know these Macho masculine
men that that absolutely are obsessed
obsessed
with trans women I mean they are hyper
focused
on people who don't even make up one
percent of the population and they also
are part of the I hate boobs crowd
which
is kind of I don't know it says more
about them than I think it does about
anything but there was a trend going
around Twitter
um this this weekend
uh let's see if we can get Gabe Sanchez
in here and see if he
see if he realizes this I don't know he
might let's see if he can um
you might be doing a sound test in the
background with our guests to make sure
um she can get there
so you got me distracted you say boobs
in the chat
now I'm I'm on this Twitter thing I'm
not kidding you this is a thing let me
see if I can find it on Twitter uh I
hate boobs crowd
it's a thing
the thing
um I'm just making sure because it's
YouTube so YouTube is really uh no see
there's a pair of tits and that's not
probably gonna work I mean I'd love to
show you because literally it's it's
just it's just
beautiful women who happen to have a
little bit of cleavage chili is what it
is
and all they were trying to do over the
weekend was absolutely trigger these
enzels and I guess it worked because
they were posting over and over and over
and over and over again and it kept
showing up in my feed I don't know why
don't ask me maybe the algorithm knows
more about me than I would like to admit
Mad Max says who doesn't like boots
I mean most I mean come on
women are beautiful okay and there's a
reason why women
are more beautiful than men it doesn't
always have to do with the boobs but it
doesn't hurt it doesn't it doesn't women
the other thing too
is women are way smarter than men that's
why this trend of the I hate boobs crowd
they're they're posting pictures of
their cleavage to trigger the I hate
boobs crowd only shows you
only shows you
that women are smarter than men
it's a prime example
that all alls they have to do to trigger
these these [__] incels brains to go
crazy and wild and not like not like um
wild like you would think because you
would think like these moglodytes
seeing a bunch of boobs on the I hate
boobs trend
would be they would be fascinated but
they're not they're disgusted
I'm not sure what it's very weird
ah boobs can make good weapons see we
got the best crowd in the world here we
are on Monday
we're not we're not even to the shitless
Roundup we haven't even got to some of
the clips of the politics and here we
are
talking about boobs
um um pulling 77 says we're the superior
gender I tend to agree with that I tend
to agree now I'm not going to say rather
or not it is the boobs but I'm not going
to say that it's not that either so
but yeah there was I and you can go to
Twitter
um here I'll show you I'll show you one
example
I'll show you one example why not let's
see if this is the original
uh no that's not the original I'm trying
to trace back where this started right
and the reason why is because they uh I
think this is uh some of the original so
here is um
happy booby Monday
love is better that
I have boobs and I love boobs yeah I
mean you know there's nothing wrong with
boobs there's nothing wrong with them
nothing wrong with them
I mean unless you know you're one of
these Patriot front incels which I'm I'm
sure we'll get to today when Gabe
Sanchez gets on here you saw that over
the weekend too that a bunch of incels
were in Washington DC
they're that's and they were dressed up
in costumes they had their underwear
over their face so you can't identify
them that they're that they're Nazis
in a course
of course but that they are the I hate
boobs crowd here here's a good example
of the um the I hate boobs oh no that's
not it
see I well that's a boob but not
necessarily the one I'm looking for
oh
wrong wrong window
I got a lot of stuff going on here okay
I don't want to pull up the wrong window
here all right here here's an example of
it what in the hell I'll do my part it's
been a while since I've been in the
fight let's trigger the I hate boobs
crowd next
I think the other one before the I hate
boobs thing was that I hate legs so
women were literally just posting
pictures of their legs and these guys
were offended
they were offended for some [__]
weird reason
that some and you know what's crazy is
like
if you watch any of the um like workout
stuff these people are losing their mind
that women are wearing Spandex and
they're wearing workout gear and [__]
and and that it's too tight and it's too
revealing in the gym because these guys
are trying to work out and they can't
they keep getting distraction by their
[__] rapey thoughts and [__] they
can't just focus on what the hell
they're doing they always got to be
[__] distracted by what someone else
is doing right
and they're trying to figure out does
this does this woman that I'm attracted
to have a penis or not they can't keep
[__] the Cycles in their brain over
and over and over again because they
can't stop reading right-wing [__] like
Tim Poole and Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro
and Charlie Kirk they can't stop
listening to these [__] idiots about
trans people so that's what they're
hyper focused on is people's genitalia
and so they get in the gym and they get
all confused and discombobulated and
it's ridiculous that they and it's
ridiculous that they think
that that they can't
that women can't wear what they want to
wear to work out in but dudes they can
just wear a pair of shorts no shirt no
don't need that no they can dance around
the gym they can they can Flex in front
of the mirror right they can show their
muscles now that's cool that's women
nope can't do that can't do that you're
you're distracting men see and when you
distract men in the gym oh man oh man
that gets in her feels so it's the same
thing same [__] crowd when they're
trolling through Twitter and they're
trying to look for any kind of hate that
they can lanch onto right so they can go
post a hateful reply for someone who's
like hey I'm a trans people Ally I I
support the lgbtq community I support
love not hate and like oh you [__] and
then they start typing same [__]
who's offended
buy a picture of women's legs and the
reason why they're they're super
offended is because they're scared
because
right-wing [__] talk radio and all
these nut jobs had convinced them that
the first thing they have to do when
they see a woman that they're attracted
to is decide what gender they are what's
their pronouns what's their genitalia
I'm dead serious this is the problem
that they have
this is the problem
um but here is an example again of the I
hate boobs crowd so it was I hate legs
and then they decided well [__] we'll
just we'll [__] with them even more
we'll do the I hate boob scrap so here's
here's a picture here's another here's
another example let's trigger the I hate
boobs crowd next
these aren't these aren't naked boobs
right
they're not
but it would it triggers the [__] out of
them apparently
oh boy
oh thank you for giving us the um
ability to talk about boobs this morning
on this Monday I don't know if Gabe
Sanchez is ready or not but
I'm gonna move on to uh
to some political clips
even though that's political too right
that's political
what do you want from me it's political
okay let's let's listen to
um Ron DeSantis I told you Rhonda Santos
was asking uh was asking a question this
morning about Donald Trump and how much
he's a loser now watch Ronda Santos here
he is very awkward when he goes on the
attack and the reason why he's so
awkward is because number one he is
wearing a human skin suit
um he is an Android he is a Nazi Android
inside of a human skin suit but the
other reason why is because he's
terrified to attack Donald Trump that's
the reason right that's the reason why
he's so awkward and someone says
cleavage Monday maybe we should make it
a thing
I'm not opposed to triggering people are
you I'm not I'll trigger these idiots
however I can
so someone says for research purposes
are you making fun of the reason why I
was um looking up
um I hate Boot and it was popping up in
my timeline what do you want from me
again maybe the algorithm knows more
about me than I know
I don't know but the I hate boobs crowd
Trend kept popping up
no pun intended kept popping up in my
timeline okay let's speak in a boner
let's go to um Rondo Santos here he's
being in a question about uh is Trump a
loser
Center
an event GOP
exact a culture of losing do you
acknowledge the Trump loss because there
wasn't all this fraud that he talked
about well I look at the last however
many election Cycles 2018 we lost the
house we lost the Senate 2020 Biden
becomes president or no excuse me we
lost the senate in 2020 Biden becomes
president and has done a huge amount of
damage very unpopular in 2022 and we are
supposed to have this big red wave and
other than like Florida and Iowa I
didn't see a red wave across this
country and so I think the party has
developed a culture of losing I think
that there's uh not uh accountability
and I think in Florida we really showed
what it takes uh to not just win win big
and then deliver big and ultimately when
you're doing all this uh what results
are you producing for people that's
really what matters uh you can sit there
and talk about cable news social media
all these other things okay okay okay so
this is this is said this morning
um someone's saying the sound is down
that's as loud as it goes that's as loud
as it goes and I'll tell you
um that's the trouble with some of these
clips that are posted online
um so this is at a press conference this
morning and you saw the placard there uh
if you need to see it again here it is
it says Florida the education State come
on man really education state so this is
a press conference about education this
morning and let me give you an idea of
what uh Rhonda said oh [__] let me uh go
back let me give you an idea what Rhonda
santis was talking about here
um in in this little speech and the
reason why is because
um he's like oh you you think we're
education State well we're going to get
rid of Education because we don't don't
want education so much so that we're
going to tell universities what they can
and cannot teach I'm not shooting you
this is real let me see my what the [__]
man where'd it go there's a clip did it
get deleted
[__] is this man
the internet the [__] internet
[Music]
um
that's that one yeah that's that one God
damn hang on a second
let me see if I can find this where's
Gabe Sanchez
where is Gabe's Aunt where in the world
is Gabe dentist
the santis let's see if I can find this
clip now this clip he's talking about
college universities and he's talking
about Berkeley here it is this is it
here it is I found it here he is uh this
morning at the same uh news conference
and this is again this morning and let's
listen if you want to do things like uh
gender ideology uh go to Berkeley go to
some of these other places that's fine
the only people talking about gender
are you [__] you're the only
people who are hyper focused on so much
so that you were willing to boycott M Ms
because they weren't the correct gender
hello
think McFly think
and I don't understand this I don't say
is the sound working okay it's just not
high enough is that it
uh someone tell me
someone say yay or thumbs up
if the sound is okay I mean I know it's
I know
I know the sound on the clips sometimes
isn't as loud as we'd want it to be
but sometimes it's it's just that's as
loud as it can get I can't feed it
through any louder uh good here okay
people say good okay soft it's soft
oh man I don't know if that's a boob
joke or not let's keep going oh boy
here's more round to Santas
fine
and there's nothing if that's what you
want to do there's nothing wrong with
that uh per se but for us with our tax
dollars we want to focus on the
classical mission of what a university
is supposed to be oh oh for our tax
dollars
Ron DeSantis
is
such a [__] Nazi okay
now
these These are universities right and
now what he's talking about is is is
State money going to universities that
are going to teach this or teach that
and they don't want it to teach that
they don't want people to learn things
that are the truth right that's the
problem here
it's what he's so offended by now let's
fast forward just a little bit right
walk on this hypothetical ridiculous
Journey for me
where Ronda santis is disparaging
universities all around the country who
are going to do this right who were
where he's going to go and sell this to
the entire country right where he's
running for president so he's saying in
Florida right the Floridian tax dollars
are not going to go to universities that
he doesn't like them having curriculum
that offends him
it's a hem problem but he's going to
make sure that they can't teach that
stuff to anyone
nope no one can learn that stuff we're
gonna take away all the books we're
gonna burn them we don't want you to
learn all kinds of stuff that that would
make sure that you vote against people
like me fascist right okay
so now let's fast forward right he's in
the capacity of Governor here let's
pretend he's going to run for president
Gabe Sanchez let's just pretend Ron
DeSantis is going to run for president
here just for a second like he was
pretending in Iowa we're going to
pretend the same way he was pretending
okay all right I mean I I okay all right
let's pretend so let's pretend he's
running for president
now he's going to go around the country
and he's going to say the government
he's right now he's saying the
government Florida because he's the only
the governor he's not the president he
never will be but he's the governor of
Florida he's saying that tax dollars
can't be given to universities with woke
ideology right okay follow me now and
they know and they know they've already
identified his lawyers have identified
in court
the injustices that are brought within
the you know within the country of
America they've identified and agreed
that woke
is is identifying those injustices that
exist so right it's not like they're
making they do exist they know what they
are they just don't want people to know
about it right okay now
let's fast forward and let's pretend
like he was pretending to run for
president in Iowa let's pretend he's
gonna run president
he's got to go around saying
I as president of the United States
because I'm pretending to run I is the
pretend president of the United States
which I will never be but I'm gonna
pretend I'm gonna be all right that's I
mean I mean considering who we've had as
president prior to this right I'd say
it's not off the table right exactly
exactly so as I'm pretending to run and
I'm pretending that I will be which I
won't be I'll pretend to be president
I'm gonna have the same policies in
Florida because I think they're good
policies I'm going to make sure that no
federal dollars go to any institution
where I Ron Hitler DeSantis do not agree
with their curriculum and I want to
censor the truth and the reason why is
because the truth does not serve my
ideology's future because once you know
the truth you would realize that I'm a
[__] bonehead and I'm Antiquated and
I'm a fascist and I probably should stop
oppressing people
that are in minority classes but he's
going to do this or maybe he'll just
pretend to do it let's let's finish up
his little diddy here on how he wants to
put big government
into schools uh we don't want to be
diverted into a lot of these Niche
subjects that are heavily politicized uh
we want to focus on the basis and who's
politicizing this besides the
Republicans who I don't know I mean I'm
pretty sure nobody had a problem with
just these course lessons or these
classes that are just are just like
Equity inequality in general it's crazy
once you come after those things Tony
that's when you know the end days are
coming Well I this is still all the the
white fright right right and what it is
is that that we're getting to a
situation in this country that that our
Constitution and our great Melting Pot
as you might want to call it has
afforded us the ability to get more
diverse as our country ages right so the
longer we go on the less white we seem
to white people and by less white I mean
like instead of 70 we're like 60 right
like it's really white here like really
white right but they're terrified
they're terrified and it's white fright
right so they're the whites are fright
frightened by the possibility that they
may be less than 50 percent of the
country which is right so
all white all white all white now that
is what Ron DeSantis is trying to have a
backstop to that's what that's what they
mean by wokism is they mean anything
that's not white supremacy right I mean
what what they're essentially doing is
they're trying to create a handicap
for themselves well
as if white people don't already have oh
no 100 handicap that is ever I mean we I
mean other than in Europe
this country you and being white you
have had the biggest handicap ever and
the reason why is because Europe has
never been as diverse as the United
States and the reason why is because the
United States is like yeah we we need
people to come here like we need
population so we'll open our borders and
they did for a long time anyone was
welcome [__] you didn't even have to do
anything but give your name and you'd
come in this country at one point now
now and
speaking of coming in the country
um did you notice that title 42 expired
expired and
um manga's biggest fear didn't happen
did you notice that yeah did you know
that the number of people who crossed
the border actually decreased whoa hey
hey easy on the truth there friend I'm
just dude it's just data the same
numbers the same numbers easy on the
truth the same you're gonna verify
Rhonda Santos he's gonna have to build a
wall between him and Georgia right he's
gonna have to build a wall between him
and the Gulf of Mexico right well I mean
it would you have a southern border that
southern border is a son of a [__]
right it would it would it would it
would really [__] up his the what
tourism he has left with his attack on
Disney and then his attack on beaches
when he builds a [__] wall on the
beach and then he tries to get Mexico to
I don't know I don't know again Rhonda
santis is such a [__] right but this
weekend
Okay so
Trump uses the excuse of tornadoes not
to have his rally now we all know from
people on the ground who were once Trump
supporters who are now the Santa
supporters not even that there's a there
there's a I've got a a person that I
mutually follow that lives in Iowa that
drove past and they were like it was
raining buckets but that was it right
well they've been like a random problems
and then I think it might have rained
again and then it just stopped but they
never had a problem you know he's never
had a problem getting sheep in a pasture
if there's rain
I know I mean like look the guy the guy
has left people out in the cold like
literal snowstorms he abandoned them in
Nebraska which isn't that far away the
idea the idea that he is like oh no I
gotta look out for the safety of my my
constituents or I look hungover it might
be because I just came back from the gym
hey Romo says I I came up from the gym I
did the I did the test with the guests
that we have on and then I took a
showers so the sound and audio did the
sound and video test go well yeah yeah
okay great great we're so we're good to
go all right well here's the thing about
Iowa is there was another video from
Iowa that's even more Awkward than just
a regular round to say at this video and
I don't know
listen I'm open to just about anything
here to get Ron DeSantis in this race I
really am I want him in the race man I
mean he's gotta do something man I I
want him to to get in this [__] race
if he doesn't step in the race he's
gonna be like a wannabe Scott Walker
right like never even got into it and
flopped right well I mean Scott Walker
didn't last more than maybe no but at
least he went into the debates though
you know that is true like he made he
made the effort of saying I'm gonna run
for president then went to the primaries
did some debates
and then he and then he fell straight on
his face but Ron DeSantis is is going to
you know going to International leaders
saying hello right leaving his
constituents in Florida to [__] be
submerged underwater right he goes to
different places like Iowa and he's like
no no no no no I'm not running for
president guys
why can't I find this [__] on my
timeline okay which one the Laughing the
burgers
I'm looking for the one in the [__]
diner with him and and the Fly I mean
like pants yeah okay this is [__]
awkward as [__] man you you've watched
the Men in Black movies I love them okay
right well I'd say the first one is
better than the other ones but yeah sure
well yeah well I mean the first one the
OG is usually the better yeah right but
here's the thing like in those movies
they they disguise the aliens in skin
suits right essentially and different
aliens have different kind of ways to be
dressed up or or appear to be humans
even some of them appear to be dogs
that maybe what the Flyers belts man
right exactly oh no that was the cat
the dog the dog was the was the um oh my
God I'm a blanket on it they go to the
newsstand and they and and Wilson that's
what it was yeah he thinks that the guy
at the newsstands an alien alien right
because he looks like Rick Scott right
and and but it ends up the alien ends up
being the damn dog but in this clip in
this clip see if you can spot the aliens
and from Men In Black in this clip here
at a diner
um see if you can see the uh the aliens
foreign
his suit jacket is so big well I mean
you know he has been packing on the
pounds to try to look as big as Trump I
mean and then his impersonation has gone
South because he can't impersonate Trump
anymore because now he can't I'll tell
you I'll tell you this much man the idea
that you're like oh I gotta pack on
pounds to add the appearance like it's
going like super meta for a role that
you're gonna be like in a movie about
and you're like this biopic about Trump
is about to come out and he's like look
I think I'm going to have a pretty good
shot at this if I if I pack on some
milkshakes it'll be the greatest
performance ever if I do a lean I pack
on some pounds I do the air accordion
thing you know it'll be totally fine
people will buy me As Trump 2.0
uh it's just [__] weird man it's just
like be who you are it is putting your
fingers out scoop it in and [__] own
it you know
suck that pudding off your fingers Ron
just do it as Nike would say okay so I'm
I'm gonna just say this out loud so that
people know that this is what I'm
thinking because when I originally seen
this clip I'm like these [__]
man these [__] these two
awkward [__] are seriously
sitting around considering a Unity
ticket now bear with me here on this
idea right they're actually sitting
around me like hey man you know what
would be fantastic if we did when I
announced my campaign if we did a Unity
ticket because Mike Pence probably
somewhere in his little p brain thinks
that he's the reason why Trump won in
16. yeah like that's probably I mean I
hope he thinks that I mean how how
[__] delicious would it be Gabe
Sanchez for these two [__] to
be running against Trump who doesn't
have anyone on the ticket and I also
just ask a question what the [__] is a
Unity ticket
huh what the [__] is a Unity you don't
know what a Unity ticket is no okay so
Unity ticket is where you're trying to
bring two sides together right you're
trying to unify something now normally
well hold on hold on that doesn't make
any sense though because well
I know I know I know I know I know you I
know you're seeing that this is a really
shitty idea but do you think these two
do you think these two would not see how
shitty idea this would be I'm telling
you I almost bet I almost the BET word
the words unity and ticket
somewhere came at it either these two
[__] amounts or their campaign
staff's mouths are there exploratory
excuse me right excuse me exploratory
yeah exploratory right right right right
right right it's because they're not
actually running
yeah you know but here's and I and okay
okay I understand I understand also why
pens might be saying things like I never
saw Donald Trump inappropriately behave
or interact with female staffers despite
the fact that female staffers are now
coming forward to be like yeah dude he
tried to [__] have sex with these
women right he tried he he's he
specifically said I want that young
Stamper to look to to walk away because
I like looking at her ass well here's
the thing I want to show you something
really quick and this is what Mike Pence
probably did he did the Jim Jordan let
me show it to you okay
that's probably why did he have an
informant or whistleblower oh well I I
mean that maybe it's I mean why I don't
know hey wait wait look there is no fly
on his head
maybe that's why it's missing is the fly
is gone the fly is lost the fly is
missing the informant has flew the coop
damn our coup made I was gonna say he
flee the coup yeah it could be it could
be it just it just makes sense that he
would fly I want to get back to this
Unity ticket idea yeah because I'm gonna
smoke this out because this is brilliant
you want to smoke this out yeah I
wouldn't touch it with a [__] 10 foot
long dude all right roll it up and smoke
it no dude I'm not putting my lips on
that bong listen we were talking about
boobs early you missed the boob stuff oh
did you see was was the uh I hate
Williams ground yep see see I knew it I
knew it it wasn't just my timeline yeah
yeah dude I saw a lot of women sharing
boobs and I was like you [__] can do
that man you go for it happy [__]
Mother's Day okay so yeah [__] yeah okay
so I'm gonna I want to smoke out this
Unity ticket idea now think about this
for a second you got to get into the
into the two brain cells that these two
have between the two of them right and
they're like look here's what we can do
do because you need to get exposed to
bring together two sides and normally it
would be like a Republican and a
Democrat being on the same ticket right
so that they could unify the country and
the country could vote for them because
it's Unity or some dumb [__] right which
will never happen
but but these two are thinking Unity
ticket because they're like look now
that Trump supporters hate Ron DeSantis
and I helped Trump win
but the Trump supporters hate Mike Pence
yeah dude they hit him so much they
tried to [__] kill him right and Mike
Pence is like I'm the bridge I'm the
missing link why do you think I'm so
excited about it these two are talking
about a Unity ticket how how much better
I mean honestly we we won't even have to
work hard to create content it won't
like like if Rhonda santis decides to
announce and Mike Pence announces with
him that he's running as his vice
president content will be so [__]
easy like it's one of the reasons why I
want why I want Rhonda scientists again
in the race is because it'll make our
job really easy to mock them I mean I
mean look at the idea look at this look
at this how easy is this
yeah yeah I'm gonna mute this and you
just tell me if you think this isn't
awkward like how hello my human yeah hi
hi is that sodi that you have in your
cup there are you enjoying those uh
sodium Rich fried potatoes delicious
sustenance
and then Ron DeSantis there awkwardly
sitting going he's like hands where do
hands go on on table on leg on leg
confirm on leg Smile Smile smirk
oh look at he's like tap tap leg once
tap nope just once tap like once look
look at the camera don't look directly
in limbs go back go back look at it look
at the head Bob ready
[Music]
39 degrees
uh Governor [__] weirdo there the
idea that these guys are coming in
they're like look we are both flesh
human uh people we would like to see
your leader or rather become your leader
like the idea that these [__] idiots
come into a diner like wholesome America
how are you doing we are two humanoid
beings who would like to be the leaders
of this free world
[__] these guys man so creepy so cringy
just off the rails but I love it well
here's just this one this is great okay
John cardillo do you know who John
cardillo is he used to be a Trumper now
he's into Santa's camera I actually I
actually liked his content this weekend
oh yeah oh man it was it was juicy it
was delicious I was retweeting it I'm
like dude you have no idea what you're
doing you honestly think that Ron
DeSantis can be president you are a dumb
[__] yeah you are you are dumber than
dog [__] but frankly man you're you're
creating the narrative that we need to
defeat you and by you I mean fascist
like you are creating the absolute
structure and and the foundation of how
this is all gonna crumble right in front
of our eyes and he tweets this this is
hilarious because there's a picture of
Ron DeSantis that has been the uh source
of many memes yeah uh over the weekend
um it I don't know is this at a a
[__] is it like at a tire shop or
some [__] I don't know where this is I
don't know to Ronda Santas he's probably
like uh look at me in Middle America I
am here where the middle class Blue
Collar people fix automobile mechanic
machines
oh [__] so John cardillo he was bashing
Trump all weekend and and of course the
Trump supporters are going after him
hard and the reason why is because he
was saying that the reason why Trump
canceled his rally is the reason why he
canceled because no one showed up unless
the tornadoes it wasn't the tornadoes
um but but anyways even Twitter notes
they're like well there were tornadoes
but they weren't really close by yeah
yeah anyways and if and if anyone's
unaware of folks in Iowa Iowans they're
they're they're they're really they have
tornadoes all the time like all the time
like it's pretty crazy it's almost like
it's a normal occurrence right it's a
tornado alley I don't know there's like
a perfect flat land where there's an
undisturbed environment that would allow
for those things to happen right right
it's weird like Kansas Northern Missouri
Nebraska
it's it's strange like again normal
everyday you know friends you know what
it is people build shelves wait for it
wait wait now I know now I know I bet
George Soros
got his antifa soldiers together and
these are antifa storms that's what this
is that's this is George Soros funded
storms that made Donald Trump
cancel his rally well John didn't think
John thought it was the is because no
one showed up and that's the reason why
and Johnny here tweeted this now he
thought that this was a sick burn he
said wait he canceled his rally because
of some weather 50 miles away and here's
Ron DeSantis not too far away act trying
to act like a human being
um
no one laughs like that uh and if you do
then other people would laugh like that
around you like hey somebody made a joke
that was hilarious but he's the only one
yeah yeah okay I said this I said funny
thing is because I was talking to John
here I said funny thing is you think
this picture of Governor weirdo is some
sort of sick burn like he thinks this is
a great burn because everyone was
cycling this this around the internet so
John tried to make it a positive here by
saying wait he canceled his rallies so
you know what you know what he's trying
to make this he's trying to make this
the Obama Clinton meme where the boat
where the both of them are laughing in
the chairs and they're like oh yes yes
and everyone use it when like he said he
could declassify the documents with his
mind all right that's so funny but when
you have no one else laughing it's
[__] weird right I mean like no one
no like literally literally no one the
people behind them the people in front
of them so what do you how do you think
this conversation went went up and he
was like hi I'm Ron DeSantis I'm funny
you know what I know how funny I am you
know what I think he did hold on let me
I just want to get the quote directly
because I know I tweeted it uh hold on
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah go ahead
[Music]
geographically if people know what I'm
thinking in my mind right now you'll
understand here we go okay so Ron
DeSantis don't know if you guys remember
this but when the parts has this book
ever actually been released I don't know
it has it been released I don't know do
Do Androids write books I mean we have
ai like yeah and he's like I got to
compute uh all right so in the book this
one that I'm sure somebody else he had
as a ghost writer write it uh because
Ron DeSantis would smear too much of the
the chocolate pudding on the actual
pages but I do I do want to point this
out
okay if you remember this okay Ron
DeSantis just to set the stage here Ron
DeSantis went to Iowa the Midwest that
many people consider they well formally
consider I'd say because we're trying to
move it to you know South Carolina for
the the the first
um uh primarily yeah for the first
primary for the at least for the
Democrats but Iowa being like hey this
is a this is a lock this is where you
understand where Middle America the
actual average person is as a you know
as an American where they're going to
vote and it'll tell you kind of
gauge wise how the country will will you
know
um accept that candidate right so Ron
DeSantis goes to Iowa
in his book he writes I was
geographically raised in Tampa Bay
but culturally my upbringing reflected
the working class communities in Western
Pennsylvania and Northeast Ohio from
weekly Church attendance to the
expectation that one would earn his keep
this made me God-fearing hard-working
and America loving
he basically was like look up synonym
for up Florida how to yeah I mean he's
like he's like look I mean sure
geographically I was raised here but
like this place is a dump
I'm a you know it's also it's like oh
Pennsylvania Ohio I'm I'm wondering why
he would have written about those those
States specifically why would he talk
about church or God or America it's
almost like he's trying to build himself
up as a potential candidate to say look
I may be down here from the swamp lands
but I'm
true American at heart I'm a Midwest boy
well we all know we all know that Ron
DeSantis is a Nazi yeah it's very clear
but did you see your favorite Nazis
showed up at DC oh they came back I
gotta move on because I gotta get I
gotta get to this and then before we get
the guest on but this they came back
again what do you mean they came back
again the second time the second time
last year okay okay I thought you meant
like they left yesterday and then they
are they left this week well they might
have run away they might have run away
and jumped in their U-Haul trucks but I
know that they for a fact they were
previously at the Lincoln Memorial well
wait I thought I thought it's not you
all anymore I thought it was you hail oh
it's you you Heil you Heil oh
why is it you higher I don't know
there's like this uh recurring
um kind of event that happens oh okay
okay you know these Nazis need
transportation and the one who was you
know
on a recurring basis able to get these
Nazis the transportation they need is
U-Haul I mean U-Haul I mean you hail I
mean you know those Nazi pleases
whatever it is whatever yeah you know
it's great this is great but it's also
great because people are like oh it's
the feds it's the [__] FBI oh my God
why do they why why when fascism is
right out in the open do Nazis be like
no it's not really Nazis they're they're
anti-nazi anti-fascists pretending to be
Nazis so that way it's a false flag and
we distract like dude you're outing
yourself because people who aren't Nazis
aren't like right look if you're like
hey man those are Nazis you'd be like
you should say and as if I needed to say
this out loud but what you should say
when you see Nazis goes Nazis bad I
don't like Nazis you should not say hey
those Nazis are not actual real Nazis
we're real Nazis those guys are not real
you get that defensive because look if
it wasn't a big deal and you know and
you really believe that Nazis were bad
as we all should I believe there should
be a I think we misspoke uh Cosmo has
that the Khaki KKK so maybe we are off
or is it the Kaki KKK or is it the Kaki
okay I I don't I don't know it could be
honest good that's a good question but
the other thing too is like every one of
these people proud boys so uh though
some proud boys who are obviously well
known won't cover their faces but proud
boys Patriot front any one of these
other people online like I had one guy
who came after me online because I made
fun because my joke is the commercial I
made or there was a bit that I made from
the last time they were at the Lincoln
Memorial which was these guys are
wearing tidy whities on their face right
and I made fun of the fact that these
guys were [__] in cell Bros who live
with their parents who borrowed their
mother's uh uh [__] frying pan cover
as their shield and was wearing
underwear on their face
I mean it kind of looks like that I mean
it does doesn't it like so this guy
online got upset at the fact that I was
making fun of these guys right and again
and again the response should be oh yeah
let's make fun of the Nazis your
response shouldn't be oh man those guys
are feds oh dude triggered much kind of
tells me by the fact just by that
response triggered much that maybe
you're triggered by the fact that you
don't like me making fun of Nazis right
you're like whoa whoa whoa they're not
actual Nazis we wouldn't get in those
kind of that like that was like we
wouldn't get in those kind of uniforms
like we're not seasoned we don't wear
those anymore do you remember the
training videos that got leaked online
they're like no no no we wouldn't touch
okay look we're not that sensual sure
we've like [__] we like to caress in
in body and strip search other people to
make sure they're real Nazis oh my God
you know what even people online were
like that's and this is people who are
from the the lgbtq community were like
damn that's pretty gay that's what they
said right what are you gonna do uh Tina
on Facebook ask you why are they
covering their faces because they're
Nazis and they don't want people to know
what who they are so they don't want to
lose their jobs because they are they
are living amongst you actually
um there was a um some news this weekend
that one of Nick fuentes's uh foot
soldiers is actually one of Paul gozar's
uh Capitol Hill staffers oh that's not
surprising at all that's that I did not
see that coming yeah okay
um so that's a little bit of news on the
Patriot front front but here's um I
didn't play any audio from that
wow [__] that's this clear we're gonna
get dinged on this or is that why you
didn't want to do it no no no no no okay
I I want to play the audio of the guy
who is um mocking them where the [__] is
it
um that video isn't going to show very
well it's gonna be small
um you know what I'm talking about I
don't know let me let me show you this
one
um it's going to be really small but
he's yelling at Patriot front because of
how this is set up
the reason why this is so [__] small
is because outside but but you just
listen to what he's saying to them okay
[Music]
you were the losers
reclaim your virginity so you know
superheroes don't always wear capes I'm
just saying no yeah I'm I'm honestly
surprised that he didn't throw out you
all have little dicks all right well he
was trying to say that without you know
oh no I know and I know that people are
like oh don't make fun of people's dicks
but they're Nazis so you know what
you're gonna give a [__] right and the
fact if you're like hey I'm gonna defend
little dick not it's like no no no don't
don't let's not defend those guys right
and defending no Nazis yeah look there
there's a there's a simple rule when you
come out of the womb when you're born
there's a universal truth and law of the
land Nazis bad punch you yeah you can
punch Nazis call them out say they got
little dicks their mom hates them they
live in the basement they're inside
cells are trying to reclaim virginity
either loser of their High School class
whatever it might be they can't get a
[__] date nobody wants to talk to
them except other Bros and the only way
they actually get touch and feel
something inside is when those Bros
actually grope them and do some sort of
weird strip down thing that the people
then film on video and then gets leaked
online it's all weird it's all [__]
weird like I Can Only Imagine
how not like German like German Nazis
would respond like 19 1940 like Nazis
would respond back to these guys and be
like oh that's pretty gay
Walter Masterson
our great friend of the show here yeah
was all over these [__] on
Twitter oh yeah so cat turd
I can't even believe I I have to say
this cat hurt posted this said dear feds
at least change the uniform okay so the
argument here is is because because the
FBI wears shitty khakis and stupid
[__] blue shirts that these guys must
be feds because they dress the same yeah
but Tony you got to remember cat turd is
also the same guy yeah who shares it
acquire is it a cat because it's a dude
it's a it's a right wing dude who lives
in Florida who you know identifies as a
cat his pronoun well yeah his pronoun is
[__] are you kidding me I well maybe I
don't know maybe I'm just trying to get
to the bottom of it okay it could be
that or it could be the fact that he
identifies as a piece of [__]
that's it that's it but what I said but
what I do want to point out is this is
remember this is the same guy who Don Jr
recently interviewed as a
I remember this we played that clip on
the show right well John Jr talking to a
cat turd he was talking about he's
talking to a cat Avatar who was like oh
yeah you you love my dad right so what
actually the guy it was it was uh it was
a filter then yeah it was yeah I don't
know I mean it it who knows well but the
other thing is
is cat turd is also the same guy who
after the footage was was released of
Nancy Pelosi actually contacting the
authorities to get the people to show up
to yes the capital he doesn't understand
his backup he said oop gotcha or or
whatever he said which basically was
like when you hold the phone to your
face there's a thing called a proximity
sensor so that your phone doesn't
doesn't touch the buttons exactly where
it doesn't oh man almost like that makes
sense it's almost like there's a reason
for things like I don't know technology
and science and they don't really
understand it but he's the same guy who
was like oh gotcha as if there was some
sort of conspiracy with Nancy Pelosi
holding the phone to her face so just
keep in mind that's the level of
intelligence we're working so he thinks
this if if people who on TV shows dress
like this and then they show up at DC to
cover their face and spread fascism
outright over fascism right then they
must be the same people because they
shop at the same Target
um here is Walter though but Walter says
in a few years these same people will be
arguing Patriot front isn't racist they
have a Latino person as leader like the
proud boys do like well proud boys
aren't aren't white supremacists they're
don't you know Enrique tario is a Latino
okay well the Neo-Nazi down in Allen
Texas also has Hispanic descent so you
know or the fact that right who you you
mean you mean you mean uh Kanye's little
Nazi Soldier yeah oh okay I thought
that's who you're talking about
um we have our our guests waiting in the
wing here
um we're gonna go to a quick break and
when we come back we're going to get to
our guest and she she is uh an expert on
Long Island everything Long Island but
here's the thing also she was apt she
was at the press conference when George
Anthony De volder Santos or Tara ravage
or as the feds on his indictment went
oh we don't know who this is who is this
guy I love it I love the indictment says
George
Anthony devolder Santos quote quote AKA
George Santos like that's his name and
they have to be like we don't actually
know this person she was there she was
there at the press conference as the
witch in this Witch Hunt comes out of
the courthouse and ask her
um some about the witch that was there
at that Witch Hunt so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back with Jacqueline
sweet talking about George Santos and
his lies right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product hard and blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
all right ladies and gentlemen I want to
welcome to the show the journalist from
Politico Jacqueline Suite she was the
one who broke the story of the veteran
dog
breeder scam every other scam imaginable
and was also there for the most recent
court appearance for the 13 felony count
indictment of George Santos or as she
likes to put it she's earning her PhD in
George santosology
welcome to the show Jacqueline wait
welcome to the show it's great to have
you thank you for having me
so you were so you go go ahead Gabe yeah
yeah so uh obviously Jacqueline you've
been covering George Santos way before I
was like I said you were the one who
broke the story on the veteran dog scam
um so I I just uh if you want to tell
the audience and share with us like how
this all got started how did you
discover
George Santos
um so I began covering his district for
local news site patch I began covering
the district in October so I first saw
him about a week before the election I
just started covering that area so I had
to cover you know so it was I was
quickly ramping up there wasn't a lot of
time to do much I did Cover a debate
that he did
um it was it was online it was a live
debate he did with his with his opponent
and I remember thinking it was very
strange and I remember calling some
people
um anyone I could think of that was like
into local politics who was smart and I
said have you seen this guy George
Santos he's so weird I swear and I
actually have gone back since it
happened to see if anyone remembers
just like like verify that this happened
and I think he's so strange and no one
had heard of him right even people in
Nassau County even people who are really
into local politics they had just hadn't
heard of him and I couldn't really
figure out what I thought was so strange
something that was like sort of like on
a like a subconscious level something
was very odd I can't say that I figured
anything out before the New York Times
broke anything but I did have that
moment that I there was something so so
off about him so in the New York Times
story broke and of course now this is my
area to cover I was like oh my God this
is amazing this is so interesting it's
fascinating this is nuts we know all
these things that he's not that he's
told us but what who is he really right
so we know where he didn't work or he
didn't go he didn't do and so the New
York Times story broke on a Monday
morning that was like the one that like
sort of blew everything up
um by that night like I was just
non-stop just researching and looking
into it I was kind of like fascinated by
like everyone else was by Thursday I was
able to break
um my first scoop on him and it was it
was a scoop that the New York Times got
to on their own the next day so it was
kind of like right there so then from
there I kind of
you know once you start doing research
in somebody once you get sort of those
scoops and those ways in one thing leads
to another so from there I just that's
how that's how my Santos scoop started
so let me ask you because Gabe has had
no success well a little bit of George
Santos replying to his request
um about his lies did you did you find
it hard to break through
um to whoever this person is that
identifies as George Santos did you find
it hard to break through in the
beginning or was it only after it really
started to get national attention or you
couldn't get the Breakthrough of of who
he was and what his lives were but more
importantly just just to get him to
admit that he's a liar
he wouldn't he never he would never
answer any of my requests for comments
um I never got a single response to him
or to his attorney So eventually go
through his attorney uh he never replied
to me I did get I did
um to this day I've only heard from him
once
um and it wasn't too it wasn't to
respond for comment
um so no he would and that was pretty
standard he really wouldn't answer
anybody he wouldn't discuss anything
um as time went on he started doing
different interviews but you know
they're obviously cherry-picked for sort
of you know
sympathetic interviewers and even you
know and and so I think that he would he
would pick and choose
people in Outlets that he thought he
could
manipulate in some way so that's pretty
standard he really doesn't really
actually talk to anyone who is going to
ask him a real question so that's kind
of that's kind of standard and it's it's
funny too because a lot of times he will
um
I've actually seen him more than once
claim that meat is biased reporters
never have never asked him for comments
he said that he's I've heard him say
that once or twice that he's never been
called for comment and of course all
never ever been called well well we know
here at this show that that's an
absolute lie yeah well that's what
what's fun right so that's right it's
almost it's almost like he's a
Republican or something to be quite
honest I mean this and you know what
when George Santos became national news
about his line I said at the time like
instantly and my audience can attest
this I said because everyone's like he
needs to resign he needs to go and I'm
like hell no why would he go I mean he's
just a typical average Republican just
telling the typical average Republican
lines but he likes all of them like he
likes all the lies right he's not
settled on a few like dozen lies he's
like I I want all of them and I want
them all to be my lies so it's almost
like he can't he can't help himself but
what I really want to know
is because I was watching the live feed
outside the federal courthouse
um and and what was funny is at one
point
um all the all the media was standing
way back from the courthouse because
there's about I don't know there's
probably three or four different levels
of steps that lead up to the entrance
the public entrance of the courthouse
and at one point one of the whoever was
reporting there one of the journalists
and it looked like a photographer said
let's move up let's move up and they all
everyone moved all the way up to that
front stairwell and I had to stop
watching before Santos came out because
there was this big tension of him coming
on so tell us what the mood was like
waiting for him to come out and then
were you surprised at the things that he
said
um yeah there was definitely a lot of
expectations so
I've been covering them for now for half
a year and this was the first time that
I saw him in person
um so that was really interesting it's
like sort of remember how many times you
see somebody on TV you know seeing
someone in person it's always like
revealing in a new way no it's just you
just kind of get more of a sense of a
person are you you get new insight um
but so so I remember so before that we
were in the courtroom waiting for him to
appear at the hearing there was also
that build up expectation so they're
probably I don't know 50 to 75
journalists really no one else was there
it was his attorney and one staffer and
everyone else was was press and it was
all the attorneys wait wait he had no
family show up to his indictment what
family does he have though wow she does
have some family here but yeah I'm not
sure there might have been a couple of
people who I don't know who they were
um okay and a staffer and his attorney
so yes most of his support was was the
media yeah so she was very support it
was very interesting because we're all
waiting in there
um and many of us have been covering him
for a long time like you're seeing
people you've talked to or you know who
they are but you've never met them in
person it was a really interesting
moment right after all this time and
we're waiting and waiting and it's a
long build up our waiting to go in the
room or waiting waiting and he finally
kind of comes through the door and
everyone's like and like gas and looks
and and it was really interesting moment
because I I had like a moment which I
never expected where I almost felt bad
for him for like a second because
like oh the whole room and the whole
energy was sort of like
sort of against him and and you know and
and judging him he and he was just it
was like so overwhelming like the
difference or just of him and then this
like overwhelming Mass
and just for a second and for a second
he almost seemed a little
like sad worried and then it kind of
went away and I think he went back into
like this sort of this sociopathic like
thing he does right so it was like for
like a second I was like I felt bad for
him maybe because like that dropped and
then it kind of went right back and but
that was one thing I never expected to
feel because like I've heard some from
so many people for so long about you
know how much he hurt them and all the
terrible things did to them and you know
I didn't expect to sort of but it was so
overwhelming the
the world against him in that moment but
yeah so afterwards statement I think
we're waiting for him to come out and
you know everyone's sort of what's he
gonna say what's going to look like
what's he gonna do we knew he was coming
and
um but then yeah then then he sort of
did
what he typically does you know if you
saw there's there's two scrums so the
scrums when everyone goes around him
um and with George Santos the scrums are
like really making chaotic there's one
scrum and he's like going into like the
sort of come on guys like you know if
you don't hey if you say please behave
that's kind of funny he's like you don't
behave you're not gonna get you know
your story so it's like kind of like at
the Trump
um indictment when he was there too
there was a big scrum that followed him
he's kind of like
there's always like a sort of a like a
victimization that he had oh no you
don't say
he went into that I
actually right so like the victim thing
if you listen it's like it it's it's
kind of sincere like she really does
feel kind of like put upon you right
he's a republican yeah but then at the
same at the same time when you look at
his you know his Santos for congress
Twitter account you you then realize
that he takes the photos from those
events and then puts them at his profile
photo or his cover photo so it's like
you know that while he plays the victim
he's clearly eating it up or he's like I
love the attention yeah I think it's
complicated right so he he he he likes
the attention in some ways he doesn't
like it in other ways I think he's like
a complicated relationship with that
like so when he feels like he's like
guys come on like I can't you guys are
like surrounding me like that's like
actually kind of sincere he actually
feels like he didn't really do anything
wrong and he's really persecuted right
so you kind of actually doesn't believe
that which is kind of interesting well
that's part of the pathological part
isn't it though I I do think he does
have a way where he he truly justifies
the things that he's done and the way he
acts in a way and so that's something
I've I've seen from covering him from
for so long he um
he he everything he's done he finds a
way to also feel that he did the right
thing and he was the right person in it
and it's a lot of like imaginations and
it doesn't make sense to you and I but
that's something he he does constantly
that I've seen for no not to convince
anyone else almost like to convince
himself so like there is something where
I think he's like a True Believer in for
himself
well you you've kind of gotten to the
mind when you were there in the room
um someone asked Margie asked here uh
someone said he looked nervous did uh
Jacqueline see that when she watched the
hearing did he look nervous during uh
his arraignment because an arraignment
the arraignment lasted I think they said
11 minutes and it doesn't take long for
a magistrate to arraign someone on
charges because basically once they say
not guilty it's
um the raiments kind of finished at that
point
um yeah so that moment when he came in I
definitely he definitely seemed
you know sad alone you know and then I
know how long that lasted um I do think
that his
um his attorneys seem nervous
um his staffers seemed nervous as
opposed to normally they they put on
like a big a big like front right a big
like she's an old friend it's like
confidence bravado that's what all they
all do and that wasn't there that was
striking to me that just just wasn't
there the body language the posture was
kind of like defeated you know it wasn't
like sort of here we are
um but then then afterwards of the press
conference he went right into like sort
of rehearsed you know and I think that
they I think that they rehearsed the the
lines are gonna you know the maiden
thing it's it's it's it's pretty
calculated yeah well I mean it was it
definitely came across as like you know
the classic what aboutism right don't
look at me I'm not the like I'm the
victim here but the real boogeyman the
real problem is over here look at Joe
Biden right and it's funny that you
mentioned the uh the lawyer because
there was a clip that was going around
where they were reporters around him
asking questions and he was just like
I'm just trying to find like he was so
lost in the parking lot trying to find
his car he was like I think uh and then
they kept asking questions he's like I
don't know wouldn't you be nervous you
know like he's never been so interesting
that you say that I really noticed that
too because Santos also did the same
thing someone said you know were you
nervous and he said well you know how
would you feel it was like if it's you
know it was my first time and then the
lawyer did that too and that's a very
interesting thing to do right like so
sort of
that's a reporter was asking him a
question for her beautiful job and you
know he's he's a congressman he's a
public figure like the way that that
kind of turnaround thing it's a very
interesting thing that they like to do
and it's um it's sort of like not like
the normal thing that is done right it's
kind of like breaking with a fourth wall
or something it's like and it's like I
don't know if it's meant to be like uh
intimidating there's something about it
that's a little odd right that you
picked up on it too yeah and especially
because like it's not his first time
because we've heard him being like we've
heard recordings of him in court for the
the Seattle case that was done right
yeah he wasn't charged right right but
like just just the fact like him being
in court in in connection with other
a you know uh people with crimes that
are that are being investigated so the
idea they're like wouldn't you be
nervous and it's like but this isn't his
first rodeo yeah but I I have to tell
you when you go into a federal court
courthouse and you surrender to these
U.S Marshals
um and you surrender
um there's a process that happens
beforehand and even after that's why I
take took George Santos a little bit to
appear out of the courthouse because
um he would have to be processed by his
pre-trial
um assessment and there's also uh work
that they have to do when they when you
actually self-surender
um because
obviously they would have to work very
hard to identify who this person was
because and George Santos doesn't even
know who he is
um but the the thing that I think is
most important here is that even though
George Santos
um may be a little uncomfortable which
most people would if you had 13 felony
counts and as Edward says in the chat I
don't have a common handy not felonies
maybe felon ish uh to um to George
Santos and if I can make a joke there
but the thing is is that George Santos
is in a lot of trouble here and the
reason why is because they have a lot of
material evidence this isn't
circumstantial this isn't this isn't the
feds you know are trying to make a case
based on
um like in the January 6 a lot of these
January 6 cases where they're trying to
get circumstantial evidence they're
trying to get into the mind of someone
George Santos stole unemployment money
from the government I mean this is kind
of cut and dry try he applied for it he
got it he took it and then there's
recordings of him saying yeah I took it
but it's not wrong because I was kind of
unemployed so it's not wrong and
justifying it so there's a lot of
material evidence to a lot of the
charges here the other material evidence
is his line to the House of
Representatives which is also material
evidence
so the idea that George Santos is saying
this is a Witch Hunt or that this is
good for his book because someone wanted
me to bring up his book here because he
said oh this is going to be great for my
book sales but the idea that George
Santos is not going to have
um a a a prison sentence here is is
far-fetched and the reason why is
because the prosecutors do have the
material evidence that's why it was so
fast to the indictment a lot of people
wondered that why can't they indict
Donald Trump when they can indict George
Santos in what seemed like two days well
the reason why is because there is real
material evidence of the crimes that he
did commit and not only that there was
informants inside his staff that were
informing on him to the feds so
is it just more of the same line
Jacqueline that somehow this is a Witch
Hunt somehow this is all [__] and
and and tell us
is he is he really is he really honestly
genuine about his lies or is it all just
paper mache to cover up this sad
insecure being that most people
recognize that most Maga are whether
it's Donald Trump or Ron DeSantis or
Mike Pence whoever it is they paper
mache over this this false uh idea of
security do you think that's what it is
or am I or am I totally off here because
he's screwed am I right here well yeah
so so I think but I think
not everything that he does so people
often want to view like even even sort
of saying The Witch Hunt stop we have a
tendency to view it through our own
lenses right so we we view through like
narrative lenses or public relations
lenses or whatever
um
so that could be a like a legal strategy
in some ways like so if they discredit
the investigation enough in some ways
that's like it's like a setting up a
legal defense so sometimes like some of
these things are calculated for
um other reasons right so you might want
to discredit
um Witnesses you might want to portray
it as a politically motivated you know
that so some of that serves dual
purposes too right so sometimes I think
we're tempted to
overly simplistically see him as just a
clown and like yeah he's a clown on some
levels too but like
you know when we sort of
underestimate you know a little bit I
think
then the commentator and the journalists
and the people on the left they sort of
get blindsided because they're sort of
you know sort of underestimating you
know him in some ways right so like he
he got this far
right he got this right well and that's
another good question about his seat
because he is still running and I I want
to believe that George Santos saw the
indictments coming
um I I want to believe that and the
reason why is because he announced his
um but he also I mean he also had there
was an ultimatum he had raised over five
thousand dollars and the rule is that
you have to either based on that at that
point you have to announce if you're
going to run or not so yeah I I agree
that he saw that coming and maybe he saw
that as a defense like Donald Trump is
running he's gonna say it's political
and I'm going to use that strategy but
he was forced in to be like he's also
going to get every dollar he counted on
the way out and every dollar on the way
in because of course he's gonna you know
that that's what they're gonna do it's
right he's gonna be raising money until
so they lock the really locked the cell
I mean that's just what he's going to do
right well so so to that point though do
you think he'll have a real Challenger
and a primary and he
um do you think he continues to run big
because I'll tell you that the timing on
this is such that a federal judge may or
may not delay a trial past 2024
especially if George Santos
um can't convince a judge that he's an
actually con an actual Contender uh in
the in the Republican ticket race not
just in the general election so so
what's the what's the feeling on the
ground there it are people really as
pissed off as they seem in some of these
interviews where where they voted for
George Santos and they're like well he
lied to us we're pissed off so do you
think there's a possibility that he will
be the Republican nominee or you think
there he's going to get primaried
um from another Republican and he won't
even end up on the general election
ballot uh well I don't even know that it
will even go that far right so I mean
but no I
both from public sentiment and from
every other Republican on Long Island no
I mean you could though you've heard
them this way there's absolutely no way
they would put put them on a ticket
um well could he even go that far to
attempt and then would that sort of
affect
the judge and the how the there's a
trial would proceed I don't know I think
that I think that Santos and his
attorney and they're they're they're
they're interested in prolonging it I
think right that does a few things it
helps them raise money just sort of
helps maybe come up with some time to
add whatever they can figure out to do
right they're not in any Rush McCarthy's
not in any Rush he's going to just get
the vote for as long as they can so they
might also want to point it out um I
don't know that him being a candidate
trying to be the candidate is going to
help anything with with the judge or his
bond conditions or anything I think I
think they're just motivated to keep it
going but
um is there a chance that he would be
the nominee I think no not at all right
people are upset there's you know
whatever the last poll was 80 percent
Republicans 90 Democrats 100
check my numbers it's somewhere around
so yeah so yeah I know people are
definitely there's no um
there's no support there's no chance so
so one last question here
um before we before we um let you go
Cynthia rice asks who paid the bail for
Santos because that's the question
everyone wants to know apparently
there's a stipulation
um I I believe that he was going to be
released of his own recognance which is
not the case
um they did order him to post a half a
million dollar bond which is unusual in
this case where you have a non-violent
crime for a federal case but it is 13
counts and he did steal government money
and he's going to be flying back and
forth to DC
um so tell us have you dug any on the
bail and who paid the bail yet or have
you found any uh crumbs that are laying
out there that we could find out who
actually helped him pay the bill or did
he
um no I I believe it was more than one
person I think it was just three or four
at the shop yeah it was it was three
three Anonymous donors
I have ideas I haven't started looking
into it I mean is it that much is that I
mean I think there's some suspects you
know that that it might be just some of
those people who have financially
supported him before
um
I don't know I guess I mean would it be
that big of a you know if it was
something somebody really crazy we
didn't expect maybe but I think the
people that it's most likely to be are
just you could probably you know go down
a list of people who eventually explored
in the most all along and they're
probably in there is my guess
well I I think I think you're on to
something there and maybe maybe we
should explore that a list of anonymous
people I don't know I'm just saying it
make for good fun why not know why not
know who was in support of George Santos
and his lies and his crimes Jacqueline
thanks for joining us and I I hope you
come back as Santos
um as he makes more news with more of
his lies and we know he will
I mean I I mean it's it's gonna it's
gonna come to some some conclusion here
morning right well you know you know um
and anything Long Island um please if
you have anything uh that you'd like to
share with the show uh please come back
and join us everyone go go follow
Jacqueline on Twitter it's j sweet L is
it I or is it l-i okay go that the link
should be in the uh are we putting the
link I also put it in the description
below so go follow Jacqueline uh and I
know she'll be following Santos
um anything else that you'd like to
shamelessly plug giveth to us
um no just stay tuned for um more in the
extended Santos universe
so more on George Santos Jackson thanks
for joining us everyone stick around
we're gonna have a few announces when we
come back we'll talk to you soon my
friend thank you very much
we'll be right back Mark
60 Seconds this Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babble
Mega Edition makes it really easy to
learn and there's lots of lessons to
choose from like subtly racist to
full-blown white supremacists their
first lesson began with learning simple
phrases and soon I was putting those
words and phrases into a conversation
each lesson takes about 10 to 15 minutes
to complete and they're all really
different which keeps things interesting
the app is really smart it actually
keeps track of the words that I'm
struggling with I chose Babel mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
lines
[Music]
which is like a full-time job what do
you think Gabe Sanchez who finds more
one question maybe we should ask
Jacqueline Who Lies more
George Santos or is it Donald Trump who
is it who is it gave sanjays which one
is it I don't know man oh no I'm on
delay now God hold on give me one second
let me go out and let me come back in
yeah right well we got like four minutes
left
all right so um I wanna I wanna go to uh
some more Eclipse here uh the main thing
is uh uh we gotta we gotta get to this
lost cause of the missing of the missing
uh informant uh here is a clip of James
Comer now let's do this while Gabe
Sanchez is is still trying to connect
his device this is James Comer the
before and the after on the on on the
evidence that they got that Joe Biden is
gonna go to prison to get more or some
dumb [__] I don't know committee chair
James Comer Congressman Comer great to
have you as always look your big day is
tomorrow all eyes on that press
conference can you give us a little hint
as to what you're going to tell us
and we're going to present the American
people with the facts the facts about
what the Biden family has been doing so
tomorrow's going to be Judgment Day and
it'll be very interesting to see what uh
Jean-Pierre and the little Ian Sams has
to say when they're presented with
evidence where where okay so that was
the day before the press conference and
then of course we know that that day
that afternoon the verdict of the E Gene
aging Carol trial happened and Donald
Trump was found that yes he is a sexual
assaulter of course he is and he defamed
her and he owes her five million bucks
for
um the damages that he had done to
Eugene Carroll now
um the next day they have a press
conference they say hunter Biden's
laptop inviting crime family at least
500 times thinking that that will get
the American people on board with them
publicly indicting the vines with no
evidence whatsoever and just saying
informant whistleblower 100 lamped up
informant whistleblower crimes
transactions Biden crime family I mean
am I wrong that's what that's what the
press conference now I listen to the
whole thing it was like mine crime
family Hunter Biden's laptop
um Russia China China China China
10 million dollars 10 million dollars
Biden's granddaughter hunter hunter
hunter hunter hunter crime crime crime
impeachment impeachment impeachment uh
and then uh when asked where'd you find
this evidence he said oh it's not
evidence where did you find it the
internet right that was that was last
year right when they were like where'd
you find the evidence he was like it's
on the Internet or did he say it in this
press conference no he said well yeah
well I mean where else are they gonna
find it no here's here's the thing the
evidence that they're using in the
transactions is off the treasury website
super secret they're reported they're
reported transactions so then what did
so so uh just uh system I understand
this so then when he said he sent four
subpoenas to get these financial
documents and disclosures was it from
the FEC or was it from somewhere else
right why why in the [__] would anyone
comply with people who don't comply with
subpoenas
[__] you we're not complying with
subpoenas why why would anyone take
their subpoena seriously well no of
course but I but I I also have to ask
like because you know
just before this I actually have a what
was that and I literally
I I I didn't get every clip because I'm
like there's so many Clips but the
pattern is is pretty much this it works
like this it says
somebody says James Comer you've got
evidence of Joe Biden uh enriching
himself through peddling influence he
goes yes we have evidence and they say
what's the evidence and then he either
says well uh we have an email that we're
very suspicious about
or he says we have a document that we
wrote a letter or there's a document
that the doj and the FBI has and they
want to get that that they want to get
access to
and on Newsmax they were like so you're
100 sure and he's like
we're pretty close to 100 right we're
pretty good 100 that it's circumstantial
and then he goes on to Fox Business
after he does his PR I think it was
after he did the press conference uh and
they were like okay so now you're making
accusations of bribery you're saying
that people are bribing these these
whistleblowers and these uh these
informants to not come forward and talk
anymore right and instead this whole
time when everyone's like hey can you
share what they said can you share what
they told you right you would think that
they would maybe drip drip drip and say
oh they made this accusation and we
verified it and they made this
accusation and they verified it and blah
blah blah however each time they're like
we'll share it to you as soon as we got
it we'll we'll get you'll know as soon
as we know right they don't have
evidence they've been unable to link
anything regarding the Biden family and
Joe Biden in China and peddling
influence nothing
and we saw that in the press conference
and then yesterday was a [__] Banger
of a day oh well let's let's watch as he
says they lost the informant and they're
missing let's listen where's that
informant today where are these
whistleblowers
well unfortunately uh we can't track
down the informant uh we're hopeful that
the informant is still there the whiskey
you can't make this [__] up man not only
not only that but in the clip like
because I think the full interview is
like seven to nine yeah or something
like that and he goes in there and and
she's like Barta Romo's like so because
because he tries to read people people
need to remember that so I have the
timeline of events on April 11th he goes
on to Fox and Friends okay and they say
hey so before you go last question exit
question
do you have evidence and then he gave a
[__] word salad response and he was
like oh well you see this and never gave
her a real answer and then Brian
Kilmeade says so you have informants
right and he goes yeah we've got
informants and they're and they're
telling us everything yeah and he's like
yeah make sure you look out fast forward
exactly one month later May 11th
he's on Fox and Friends again now Tony
tell me um did something happen between
April 11th and May 11th probably oh what
was that
are you asking me yeah to tell you yeah
because I don't know what you want me oh
I was gonna say what I was asking was
during the time of April 11th and May
11th there was a big settlement that was
done between Dominion
oh oh you're saying that Fox News can't
lie about this is that what you're
saying so now they got to be super
careful about what they say so May 11th
comes around last week he comes on to
Fox and Friends and ducey's straight up
like look you don't have any actual
evidence it's speculative and you have
some stuff that you think might allude
to something but you don't actually have
evidence right because again Murdoch
just agreed to pay out
787.5 million dollars and he's now
looking at uh smartmatic which from what
I read today looks like they have an
even stronger case than Dominion so
they're [__] so Rupert Murdoch's like
look guys we can have mine but we gotta
we gotta at least like say that we don't
agree with it or we gotta like at least
uh rebuttal this or whatever
so on Sunday when he goes on to Maria
bartoromo show and she starts asking her
questions she's like oh my God what are
you talking about here's here's the clip
watch this
did you just say that the Whistleblower
or the informant is now missing
well we we're hopeful that we could find
the employment now remember these
informants are are kind of in the the
Spy business
the Spy business he's like look they're
good they're good at hiding man those
spies are real good
teams Gabe zinjes I think I think I have
found oh my god
um I think I found a wanted poster for
the missing informant here man U.S House
Republicans missing informant name with
hell last scene March 4th because that's
when they're claiming they last heard
from this person was March 4th it is now
May 15th so you're telling me for the
past two plus months all of these
interviews this is who they're looking
for right right so all of these
interviews remember March 4th he was on
Fox and Friends on April 11th and said
yes we do have an informant and they're
telling us everything yep as of March
4th so this is the inform in here this
is this is the involvement this is who
we're looking for it is
they're full of [__] [__] man there's
no informant there's no informant and
there and probably frankly there's no
legitimate whistleblowers here no
there's just all [__] also it's this
document this document that they claim
exists they're like oh this document
shows that Vice as President Biden while
he was vice president was uh basically
trying to uh hold up money or like hold
up these these um you know governments
or these these officials for money right
he's he's trying to make money off of
his influence as vice president
okay fine right let's go with that uh
but you literally have no it's one
document supposedly one document that
proves that he did it don't you think
that if someone were to Pedal influence
there would be possibly more than one
document multiple occurrences of this
happening uh not just one time
but also if there was a trail that you'd
be able to track it and actually be able
to say hey yeah he did commit these
crimes you know and I'll you know I I
know that Tony agrees with me
if a crime was committed and somebody
used their power and their influence to
benefit and enrich themselves they
should be investigated right Hunter
Biden Joe Biden whoever it is
whatever you want let's [__] call a
spade a spade here and and hold these
people equal Jared Kushner Donald Trump
Hunter Biden Joe Biden if all these
people
like you know a crime is still a crime
so we should you know no one's Above the
Law right
but that's the thing here is they really
don't give a [__] they don't care they
don't care they don't adhere to reality
they're not Tethered to it we truly are
at the intersection of WrestleMania in
real life this next tweet that I'm about
to show you before we go is full proof
of this
um you remember the bunlight thing they
keep yammering about the Bud Light thing
I actually had a couple of Bud Lights
yesterday and I honestly I had two Bud
Lights with our we had pork steak we had
potatoes nice we had corn on the cob
that sounds apple pie it was [__]
good man and I had two Bud Lights and I
I want to reassure manga I after
drinking those Juba lights I did not
think about changing anything about my
genitalia oh I was gonna ask if you I
did not if you turned gay or something
that's what they that's what they say I
know the beer you turn gay I know but it
didn't happen but I there's a new
swimsuit edition for Sports Illustrated
have you seen the news no I haven't oh
my God this is going to make their heads
explode
um so and Larry Tenney here has um this
Tweet now this is Kim Petrus I didn't
know who this was apparently she has an
album with the name sounds familiar she
she has she's a she has an album with
cardi B now this may be fake I don't
know but I think this is funny as [__]
um and the reason why is because
uh earlier in the episode we were
talking about the
um the crowd of that doesn't like boobs
they're sensitive why don't they don't I
I don't know why I don't know why
literally but she's beautiful Reborn
boobs are like you know the source of
life for you right so she's she's
beautiful right yeah yeah very pretty
Kim Petrus I I didn't know who she was I
had to look her up this morning she's
she's uh German she's from Germany
um larrier says maggots went off on
Budweiser uh put influencer Dylan
Mulvaney on the uh bud can for a social
media promo
their [__] minds are gonna be blown
when they realize that they their sons
are jacking off
sorry jacking off to a photo of a German
pop star Aunt Kim Fincher's
uh in the 2023 Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Edition do you know why this is
so significant
you're gonna tell me I I'm I'm gonna
tell you I have a feeling but I don't
want to say it but Kim Kim here is a
trans woman shut the front door you shut
the front door no she you're telling me
that these [__] right-wing maggots
are gonna have this Sports Illustrated
2023 swimsuit edition
in their cars in the bathroom private
time yep yeah I had to look it up I
didn't know this I had no idea I didn't
know I didn't I don't know I know she
was I had no idea I didn't know the same
way is I didn't know who Dylan Mulvaney
was until Kid Rock started shooting his
guns at Bud like well that's how it I
mean it's like I had no idea like I was
like I had no idea that what happened my
light was so Progressive I had no idea
it's the [__] Streisand effect man
they're like we can't talk about this
and then they cause more attention right
they're like we can't we gotta ban it we
gotta cancel we gotta shut it down we
gotta suppress it we can't let you talk
about this but the more that you shoot
it and [__]
and the more that they whine about
something and say that this is the total
degradation of humans
that's why the name sounds familiar
Donald Allen points it out here on
YouTube he says
yes that's it yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
that's right yeah yeah I remember right
that's I remember when they freaked out
familiar this morning I was like now I I
I've heard this name and apparently um
Kim has a new album or something or new
song with um with cardi B I think so
yeah and and I don't know if she's
actually gonna be on this uh cover
Sports Illustrated this appears to be
the Sports Illustrated hey if you want
to look it up to see if that's what I
mean it looks I mean I don't know it's a
pretty good what what I'm saying though
is she's hot and it's really gonna
[__] piss him off here's why it's
gonna piss him off is because when I
looked this up this morning I found out
they him she's she's an adult and she's
a trans woman but I I don't I think she
has had full reassignment surgery four
four women
who are on this yeah because because
that's what Sports Illustrated does
right right is you want to know they
have different covers yeah yeah sure why
not uh
uh so Martha Stewart
oh that's really gonna piss him off too
Megan Fox Okay real excited about that
one right uh Kim Petrus yeah and Brooks
Nader I don't know who Brooks Nader is
but I I don't know either another woman
regardless it's for women now on wait
wait wait are you telling me are you
telling me that there is there's gonna
be Martha Stewart in a swimsuit on do
you have a picture of it yeah yeah
[__] send me the link I want to see
Martha okay dude send you the link all
right dude I get it no no I'm gonna show
it I don't know if you want me to send
you I mean I'm gonna maybe save it for
later too I I don't discriminate man
wanna do I don't discriminate look that
that's why this is gonna be [__]
fantastic because they're gonna be all
[__] confused the only disappointing
thing about this whole situation with
the swimsuit edition is that Tucker
Carlson isn't on Fox News anymore
um man it's really gonna [__] that sucks
man
um let's see how she's the first oh so
in February Kim Petrus was she's a 30
year old German pop star who's the first
transgender woman to win a Grammy award
for best pop Duo group performance for
the collaboration with Sam Smith on the
on the track Unholy oh my God Martha
[__] and you know what you know what
guess what guess what on you know unlike
uh some people uh within the trans
Community Who attack
people within the community as well
um you're talking about
um
um the Kardashians stepmom what's her
name uh yeah uh uh wow case no no no
[__] it's Jenner why do I Caitlyn Jenner
yes Caitlyn Jenner yeah why I try to
believe that stupid I was like that
again I blanked at it but according to
this
she's proud that the trans Community is
inspired by her work and she uses her
platform to encourage others to reach
for the stars regardless of the gender
of sexuality crazy it's almost like hey
I'm a person and I want you to achieve
things as a [__] person regardless of
where you you know find yourself uh what
you believe you are what you're
comfortable with
it's almost like hey those things don't
matter
and just the fact that you feel
comfortable and safe and and true to who
you are that's what matters but you know
that's crazy for Republicans they
[__] get real uppity in that [__]
look at this the audience is loving this
photo of Martha Stewart she's [__]
sexy man how old is Martha Stewart look
that up
um
Martha Stewart is
you get it girl good God there's there's
more there's [__] more of Martha let
me see if I can find um there you go
here's another one Martha Stewart right
81 she's 81 man no that's crazy people
are worried about people are worried
about Joe Biden being old and being a
president look at Martha Stewart man
getting it on the couch here hello 81.
that's crazy don't be an Aegis
[__] I'm telling you it's it's
she a detriment is now 80 is the new 30
[__]
check this out check this out so she's
also yeah so she's a mother and a
grandmother I didn't know that uh but
she's also now the oldest uh Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit cover model in the
publication's history that's fantastic
good for Martin that's crazy for Martha
someone says where's Snoop Dogg is Snoop
Dogg in any of these because like any
time you see Martha Stewart anywhere
Snoop Dogg's like right there he's
always there just blazing I think you
think do you think
you know what I'm saying do you think
Martha and Snoop you know what I'm
saying doesn't Snoop have a wife though
he has a phone I mean why right but I
mean that doesn't I'm just
uh
I don't think so I don't know okay
they're just friends they're just yeah
they're just friends they're friends who
smoke and cook together because they
have that show I think I think friends
it can especially if you are of the same
gender that you are attracted to right I
think friends can love each other they
can have closer relationships
and they it doesn't have to be it can be
platonic in other words yeah yeah but
you can really love each I'm just asking
the question I just asking absolutely
fine that's totally fine I'm sure I'm
sure there are some people out there
some real
but Martha is a mega [__] smoke show
man I know man oh my God Griffin also
say you know money buys you a lot of the
luxuries
super rich but also one I mean I mean
yeah she looks great 81 that's look at
that pair of legs that'd be a sand
she's pretty hot man she's pretty
[__] hot I'm just saying all right
it's gonna piss him off I honestly as
beautiful as Martha looks as beautiful
as Kim looks on the on the cover
um as beautiful as they look it's gonna
it's gonna be the same thing that
happened with the with the the drag
shows they're getting all [__] up
well because they started to have
feelings they said hey all right person
exactly the person is actually
attractive right have some sort of
sensation in my body and I don't know
what's going on
I got the feels doesn't have the penis
if there's any if there's any message if
there's any message it's that it's gonna
be okay right and if that's how you feel
that's how you feel and no one should
[__] uh should should should make you
the villain you know it's it's all right
it's gonna be okay your your sensitivity
and your fragility is gonna be okay it
really is it's not gonna hurt but I'm
gonna love the ever loving [__] out of
it as you [__] lose your minds like
they did when lizzo when lizzo post any
picture online where they think she's
not beautiful because they don't think
she's beautiful right and come on man
come on just keep scrolling [__]
but they can't they can't I I cannot
wait to see
the magazine sales for that because I'm
I I don't know if they have like
multiple covers on one edition or if
it's like four different editions or
four different covers for the same
Edition kind of thing so I'd be curious
to see you know which ones are are most
purchased right and also where those
things are purchased I would love to
know what you're saying if it's like in
the middle of [__] Iowa and there's a
bunch of [__] Kim Petras oh damn
Missouri let me take Montana or whatever
listen in manga country that that Kim
cover is gonna sell better than any any
of the others
and I've always seen the others and it's
and and the one reason why is because
they're gonna be like did you know that
there's it's really hot oh [__]
I mean I I if I had enough money to
purchase a ton of magazines yeah I would
send them out randomly to Middle America
to to areas
like yeah yeah
pamphlets but I would yeah just tear the
cover off and just drop the cover not
even the [__] because look at the mag
is in the magazine you know they're
gonna do an expose on Kim and they're
gonna say and they're gonna say they're
gonna talk about her they're gonna tell
her history they're gonna tell her story
in the truth of the story and it's
really gonna [__] them up because
there's probably beautiful pictures of
her on the inside and it really I don't
know oh they're gonna like [__] yeah
so you guys the real thing the real
kicker is like if one of these people
right
ends up doing a spread on I don't know
something like Playboy right easy easy
easy
not only not only not only are there is
there sense of sensitivity really banged
up here but you start using the words
spread oh man that's really gonna get
him confused I'm just I'm just saying
they you know it's so what I was saying
was I would love to just drop these off
randomly I would like look up political
maps and find out red like [__] die
hard red districts
hand them off and say man check this you
know check her out yeah man
and then they say let me get one of
those yeah
and then give them the rest of the
magazine later on right and say here you
should totally read up on her she's
great right and then see what happens oh
yeah no she's like [__] minds you
want to hear the beautiful human you
want to hear the best Playboy story I
have sure okay I've already told my
Playboy story here's here's the oh yes
yes yes I remember you may be um his his
son anyways
anyways that was a long time it was like
a year ago and I still remember that
okay so here's the thing
um there there was
um a a a a person who was on Survivor
her name was Heidi and she was a junior
high gym teacher a Middle School gym
teacher my hometown for a bit I wasn't
in the junior high at the point that
point thank God I now she went on
Survivor she had to get naked to have a
Snickers that was the episode I don't
remember
if I was on an island you were [__]
starving man you might do you might do
all kinds of things for his secrets but
she got naked the school lost their mind
now you got to remember this is all
recorded survivor's all recorded yeah
yeah it's like it's not like she's off
somewhere while these episodes are
playing she is still a teacher in a
school
and no school no no it was for peanut
butter that's what it was for because
the very next day all the kids at the
middle school brought in jars of peanut
butter there was peanut butter okay so
she was working at the school when the
show was airing that's right correct
okay correct so so she didn't she didn't
um she didn't quit her position as the
teacher while the show was playing right
but it was all pre-recorded she did it
on her summer break but the very next
day after that episode all the kids
brought peanut butter into the school
right okay you follow
and they try to fire they didn't like it
she was on TV she took the top off you
know it's [__] stupid [__] same [__]
beat today Republicans losers what was
the reason huh what was the reason she
she got her boobs out but it was on it
was all censored so I'll send it okay so
it was censored and it was not during
right they didn't like they didn't like
that she was on Survivor she was getting
famous she married um
damn what's his name he's uh he's a he's
a baseball player he played for Phillies
for years Hamilton anyways the point is
this
what really did it in is her and another
cast member of the Survivor
they had a photo shoot in Playboy oh
okay now both of them were very good
looking I was actually a senior in high
school when all this happened
um and she came and to the high school
and spoke in the auditorium about her
experience with Survivor and the issue
and she hadn't been in Playboy yet it
hadn't been released yet
and I told my teacher at the time I said
hey can I go in there and say something
to her and he's like what are you gonna
say I'm like I just I just want to talk
to her you know it's like okay so I went
in the Jet and I asked her to marry me
she said no
I thought I'd give it a shot man yeah I
mean look you shoot your shot and you
see you know hey look I figured it never
no never know you never you never know
what to ask so I asked she told me no I
said yeah fair enough I figured I'd try
but anyways so a couple months later the
Playboy releases right
and
I may have went to the gas station to go
where there all the Playboys were sold
at the time I may have went there to buy
one it's possible I may still have it
actually
anyways so I'm I'm standing in line and
my high school art teacher she's
standing in front of me right she's
standing in front of me and I'm like hey
how are you and she's like great she's
like are you here to buy the Playboy too
I'm like yeah I am are you she's like
hell yeah I'm gonna get a couple copies
I was like this is fantastic it it
um miss a shout out to miss Gainey
because she is the best artist gamer she
is the best art teacher in the world but
that is one that is the best Playboy
story that I have is when I went to buy
the Playboy may have went to buy I may
have allegedly allegedly we know it must
uh as much as you were in the the store
to purchase but we don't know if you
actually purchased I I may allegedly I
did and I allegedly still may have it
somewhere okay okay but my art teacher
um was standing in front of me now
um and this is the same art teacher of
my junior year when someone decided it
was a good idea as a senior prank to use
diesel fuel to paint a a penis on the
football field the art class had to go
paint over this penis our must our our
mascot was the Mustang so we paid I need
a big horse head over this huge dick Oh
I thought you were gonna just fill out
the body no I mean
not Miller yeah
funny part about Miss Gainey when she
went out to look at this thing because
they called her like hey you gotta come
out here and figure out how the hell
we're going to cover something it was
homecoming week it was homecoming we had
to paint over this thing Miss Gainey
goes out to the field she comes back in
she's [__] pissed she's livid Gabe
she's like I can't believe this these
two boys were art students of mine and
this is that is not how you draw a dick
yes and she goes to the Whiteboard she's
like this is how you draw a penis it
should know better
oh oh she's the best teacher I've ever
had and it's probably the reason why I
am the way I am and that is the reason
why education is important and it's so
important for you to support people who
want to fund public education and make
sure that we have teachers who are open
and honest with children and they do not
hold back and it's not about ideology
it's about Humanity it truly is and she
was a true decent good human and she
taught us how to be good decent humans
so shout out to um Miss Gainey my high
school art teacher there as we close
Today's Show it's been an hour two and a
half hours we couldn't go without
talking about Playboy yeah
oh by the way Miss Gainey she
was she was almost retired when I was a
senior and she was a smoke show so oh
you're saying I'm just saying just
saying just saying here's to all the
mothers out there here's all the smoke
shows out there here's to all the people
who are allies of those mothers and
those smoke shows
same time same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass speaking